สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
19 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มกราคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
คะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่
18 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มกราคมปีพ.
อะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วัน
ศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
20 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มกราคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไร
คะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 10:00
น 10 นกี่นาที 3 นาทีค่ะค่ะตอนนี้ 103 น
นะคะก็เป็นตอนเช้าเนาะอืเป็นเวลากลางวัน
นะคะอืกลางวันค่ะใช่แล้วเนาะเพราะช่วงนี้
ก็เป็นใช่มคะผู้หญิงใช่มั้ยคะครูฟ้าผู้
หญิงค่ะครูหญิงกินข้าวแล้วใช่มั้ยคะครู
หญิงเนี่ยกินข้าวแล้วครูฟ้าล่ะคะกินข้าว
หรือยังครูฟ้าก็กิน
ข้าวแล้วค่ะอืมครูฟ้าเนี่ยครูหญิงฟัง
เสียงครูฟ้าเสียงเวลาครูฟ้าพูดอืเหมือน
เสียงไม่ค่อยโอเค
ออคอไม่โอเคใช่ค่ะครูหญิงครูฝ้าเนี่ยเจ็บ
คอใช่มั้ยอืออ่าครูหญิงรู้ทำไมครูฟ้าเจ็บ
คอครูหญิงรู้ได้ยังไง
อ้าเมื่อคืนตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยคืนของวันที่
18 เนี่ยเมื่อตอนกลางคืนครูฟ้าไปไป
ปาร์ตี้มาใช่ไหมไป
ปาร์ตี้แล้วก็ดื่มโค้กดื่มเปปซี่ดื่มสรท
ดื่มอะไรไม่รู้แล้วก็นอนเนี่ย
ตี 3:00 ดี
กว่านอนตอน 3:00 นใช่ไหมยไปปาร์ตี้แล้วก็
เต้นๆๆๆๆๆแล้วก็พูดๆๆปาร์ตี้เนี่ยอเออนี่
ไงคุณหญิงมีรูปนี่นะนี่ไงเนี่ยปาร์ตี้ใช่
ไหมปาร์ตี้เนี่ยน่าจะมี
เพลงเพลงเนี่ยอันนี้อนี้คือเพลงเหรอคะไม่
สวยเลยนะคะมีเพลงใช่มยมีมีลำโพง
อ่ะมีเพลงตุ่มๆๆๆเสียงดังเวลาครูฟ้าพูด
เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็อาจจะต้อง
ตะโกนอยู่ที่ไหนใช่มพูดเสียงดังอ๋อเวลา
คุยกันก็เลยเจ็บคอใช่มยคะครูฟ้าไปปาร์ตี้
มาใช่มเมื่อคืนนี้ครูหญิงคะคะครูฟ้าไม่
ได้ไปปาร์ตี้มาครูฟ้าไปปาร์ตี้เมื่อไหร่
ล่ะเออใช่เ้างั้นถ้าเมื่อคืนเนี้ยครูฟ้า
ไม่ได้ไปปาร์ตี้มาแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยจำได้ม
ว่าครั้งล่าสุดที่ครูฟ้าไปปาร์ตี้มาเนี่ย
เมื่อไหร่
ครั้งล่าสุดที่ครูฟ้าไปปาร์ตี้
มาไม่ใช่เมื่อคืนใช่มครูฟ้าคิด
ว่าจำได้มย 2 ปีที่แล้ว
เหรอ
ะครั้งล่าสุดที่ครูฟ้าไปปาร์ตี้มาคือ 2
ปีที่แล้วก็ปี 2  21 หรอใช่คิดว่าน่า
จะ 2 ปีที่แล้วนะคะอือเอแล้วครูฟ้าจำได้ม
ว่าเดือนอะไรที่ครูฟ้าไปปาร์ตี้มาครั้ง
ล่าสุด
เนี่ยน่าจะ
เดือนน่าจะเดือนธันวาคม
อ่าเดือนธันวาคมปี 2021 ใช่มคะคือจะให้
ครูหญิงถามวันที่คหญิงก็คิดว่าครูฟ้าน่า
จะจำไม่ได้แล้วนะเพราะมันนานอยู่นะ 2 ปี
ที่หรือว่าจำได้คะจำ
ได้จำวันที่ได้ก็น่าจะ
ช่วง 31
ธันวาคมถึง 1 มกคิดอ่าประมาณแบบปีใหม่ใช่
ไหมเอ้างั้นปาร์ตี้ครั้งล่าสุดที่ครูฟ้า
ไปเมื่อเดือนทันธันวาคมปี
2021 เป็นปาร์ตี้อะไรคะครู
ฟ้าปาร์ตี้ที่ครูฟ้าไปเมื่อเดือนธันวาคม
2021 น่าจะเป็นปาร์ตี้ปีใหม่
อืถ้าอย่างในในรูปนี้เนี่ยเป็นปาร์ตี้
คริสต์มาสเนาะดูจากว่ามีมีต้นคริสต์มาส
แล้วก็ทุกคนเนี่ยมีของขวัญนะคะมีการร้อง
เพลงก็น่าจะเป็นปาร์ตี้คริสต์มาสแต่ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยไปปาร์ตี้ปีใหม่เพราะว่าครูฟ้า
บอกว่าประมาณวันที่ 31 ธันวาคมแล้วก็ 1
มกราคมนะคะเป็นปาร์ตี้ปีใหม่อืใช่ค่ะครู
ครูฟ้าจำได้มั้ยว่าปาร์ตี้ปีใหม่เนี่ยที่
ครูฟ้าไป
เนี่ยอืปาร์ตี้ครูฟ้าไปที่ไหนเออครูฟ้าไป
ปาร์ตี้ที่ไหนที่บ้านเพื่อนมั้ยนี้อันนี้
เป็นครูฟ้าใช่มยแล้วก็มีเพื่อนเพื่อน
เพื่ออาจจะไปปาร์ตี้ที่บ้าน
เพื่อนร้าน
อาหารครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้าไปปาร์ตี้
ที่ราชบุรีนะคะ
อ๋อก็คือปาร์ตี้ไม่ได้อยู่ที่พัทยาไม่ใช่
กรุงเทพไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯน่าจะเป็น
คอนเสิร์ต
อ่าอันนี้อะไรคะประเทศไทยเก่งมากอันนีุ้
อันนี้พัทยานะคะบ้านครูฟ้าอันนี้กรุงเทพ
เนาะกรุงเทพฯนี้เชียงใหม่นะคะ
อืเชียงใหม่ราชบุรีอยู่ประมาณนี้เนาะใช่
อ่าราชบุรีปาร์ตี้ที่ครูฟ้าไปเนี่ยก็คือ
ที่ราชบุรีนะคะเป็นอ๋อเป็นทั้งปาร์ตี้
แล้วก็เป็นทั้งคอนเสิร์ต
อืถูกต้องอฟ้าน่าจะไปคอนเสิร์ตนะคะไป
คอนเสิร์ตแล้วก็มีปาร์ตี้กับเพื่อนๆที่
นั่นด้วยนะคะ
เดี๋
อืแล้วครูฟ้าไปกับเพื่อนใช่มยคะปาร์ตี้
คอนเสิร์ตเนี่ยไปกับเพื่อนค่ะขับรถไปอื
ขับรถจากพัทยาหรอขับรถจากกรุงเทพฯค่ะอา
จากกรุงเทพแล้วก็ไปราชบุรีขับรถกี่ชมอ่ะ
คะครูฟ้าจำได้
มยครูฟ้าคิดว่าไม่ไกลมาก
นะน่าจะ 1 ชม 1 ชั่วมงอืเนาะไม่ไกล 1
ชั่วโมงคือครูฟ้าอาจจะไม่รู้นะคะนักเรียน
เพราะว่าเวลาที่ขับรถเนี่ยเพื่อนของครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยขับรถครูฟ้าเนี่ยหลับ
หลับทำไมครูหญิงถึงถามว่าจำได้มยเพราะครู
หญิงรู้ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยหลับนะนะคะถ้าเรา
หลับเราไม่รู้เพราะว่าพอเพื่อนขับรถแล้ว
ก็จากกรุงเทพฯใช่มั้ยเพื่อนขับรถอืขับรถ
จากกรุงเทพฯ
ูถึงราชบุรีเพื่อนก็สบอกฟ้าฟ้าอะไร
ราชบุรีแล้วตื่นตื่นได้
อ่าอืแต่ไม่รู้กี่ชั่วโมงอ่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไปปาร์ตี้ที่ราชบุรีตอนนั้นเนี่ยกับ
เพื่อนใช่มยไปกับเพื่อนกี่คน
อืนี้
ฟ้าไปกับเพื่อน 5 คนค่ะ
อ๋อเพื่อน 5 คนเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนผู้ชายแล้ว
ก็เพื่อนผู้หญิงรวมกันหรือว่าเพื่อนผู้
หญิง 5 คนเป็นเพื่อนผู้หญิง 5 คนอ่าไม่มี
ผู้ชายเนาะไม่มีผู้ชายอืไม่มีผู้ชายไปกับ
เพื่อนผู้หญิง 5 คนรวมครูฟ้าก็ไปด้วยกัน
ทั้งหมด 6 คนคนอืม
รถ 1 คัน 2 คันรถ 1 คันค่ะ
อ้อได้สิเนาะเพราะว่าก็ตรงนี้คนขับ 1 คน
อืแล้วก็ตรงข้างหน้าเนี่ย 2 คนแล้วก็ข้าง
หลังเนี่ย 1  1  2  3  4 เนาะผู้หญิง 4
คนเนี่ยนั่งข้างหลังได้นะคะ 4 คนอืใช่ๆก็
ไปด้วยกันกับเพื่อนใช่มั้ยคะแล้วที่ไป
ปาร์ตี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าทำอะไรบ้างที่ปาร์ตี้
ตอนที่ไปปาร์ตี้นะคะครูฟ้าทำโควิดเทสนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะอันนั้นไม่เกี่ยวกับปาร์ตี้หมายถึง
ว่าคุณเนี่ยเต
กินอาหารร้องเพลงนี่ไงๆไงเห็นมยอย่างใน
ปาร์ตี้เนี่ยปาร์ตี้นี้ใช่มั้ยผู้ชายคน
นี้เนี่ยเค้าก็แต่งต้นคริสต์มาสอ่าอันนี้
เขาคก็คุยกันอันนี้ก็มีของขวัญคนนี้ก็
ร้องเพลงเอออันนี้ที่เขาทำไม่ใช่โควิด
เทสทุกคนทำโควิดเทส
ไงเออแต่อันนี้เขาอาจจะทำโควิดเทสเนี่ย
เสร็จแล้วใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินค่ะกินอื
เ้นมยเต้นนิดหน่อยนะคะแล้วก็ร้องเพลงโอ
ครูฟ้าร้องเพลงอะไรจำได้มย
จิงกาเบลจิงเอ่อปีใหม่นี่
เนาะว่าจำได้ว่าพลงไทนะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าไป
ปาร์ตี้อันนี้เนี่ยดูคอนเสิร์ตด้วย
อืมีนักร้องอแล้วก็ร้องเพลงครูฟ้าก็เลย
ร้องเพลงใช่ค่ะก็เลยร้องเพลงนะคะแต่จำว่า
อืมเพลงไทยค่ะแต่จำไม่ได้เพลงอะไรนะคะได้
ค่ะแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ในปาร์ตี้กี่
ชั่วโมงอือยู่ในปาร์ตี้ทั้งหมดเนี่ยกี่
ชั่วโมงโอห
2  3  4  5 นับนานนะ 6 น่าจะประมาณ 7
ชมงูฟ้าชั่วโมงเหนื่อยมากนะคะ 7 ชมงอยู่
ในปาร์ตี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยปาร์ตี้เ่อ 7 ชมนะคะ
แล้วครูฟ้าจำได้มยว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยกลับบ้านเนี่ยกี่โมงอาจจะเก็ได้นะ
อืปาร์ตี้เสร็จใช่มย 7 ชมงเนี่ยครูฟ้า
เนี่ยกลับ
บ้านกี่โมงประมาณออก
จากกลับบ้านใช่มั้ยคะครูหญิงใส่ออกจาก
ปาร์ตี้ใช่มยปาร์ตี้เต้นๆๆร้องเพลงกิน
อาหาร 7 ชมงเนี่ยเสร็จแล้วแล้วก็ออกจาก
ปาร์ตี้กลับบ้านเนี่ยกี่
โมงประมาณ 3:00 น
3:00 น 3:00 นใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ PM นะคะนัก
เรียน 3 ใช่มยอู้
หู 2:00  1 นเยง 23:00 น 22:00 น 21:00 น
20:00 นโอ้โหก็คือครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่
ปาร์ตี้ตั้งแต่ 20:00 นจนถึง 3:00 ึง 3:00
ค่ะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าออกขับรถออก 3:00 นถึง
บ้านก็ประมาณ 4:00 น 5:00 นนะฮะถึง
กรุงเทพฯใช่มั้ถึงกรุงเทพถึงบ้านที่
กรุงเทพฯอ๋อแปว่าครูฟ้าไม่ได้นอนไม่ได้
นอนที่ที่ราชบุรีใช่มั้ยราชบุรีเนี่ยใช่
อันนั้นแรดรนะคะอื
แดบราชบุรีเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ได้นอนใช่มยก็
กลับกรุงเทพฯโแล้วสนุกมยคะปาร์ตี้สนุกมย
สำหรับครูหญิงเห็นหน้าครูฟ้าหลังจากที่
ครูหญิงถามแล้วิต้องคิดครูฟ้าต้องไม่สนุก
เท่าไหร่แน่ๆใชเหนื่อยมากนะคะครูฟ้าไม่
ชอบปาร์ตี้คนเยอะๆนะคะก็เลย
เหนื่อยใช่ก็เลยเข้าใจได้ค่ะเพราะว่า
ปาร์ตี้ครั้งล่าสุดที่ครูฟ้าไปก็คือ 2021
อ่ะ 2 ปีที่แล้วแล้วในปี 20  2 ครูฟ้าก็
ไม่ได้ไปปาร์ตี้ที่ไหนเลยไม่เลยค่ะเพราะ
ว่าไม่สบายนะคะอืไม่ได้ไปปาร์ตี้ที่ไหน
เลยนะคะอือืนั่นแหละค่ะแล้วครูหญิงล่ะครู
หญิงเนี่ยไป
ปาร์ตี้ครั้งล่าสุดเมื่อไหร่ครูหญิงไป
ปาร์ตี้ครั้งล่าสุดเนี่ยปี 2022 ค่ะครู
ฟ้าปีที่แล้วอ
อะไรเดือน
อะไรวันเนี่ยจำไม่ได้นะคะแต่เดือนเนี่ยจำ
ได้ค่ะเดือนธันวาคมเหมือนครูฟ้าเลยเนาะ
เดือนธันวาคมปี
ออประมาณวันที่ 10 มั้ย 10  11 ธันวาคมนะ
คิดว่าออือๆๆก็โอเคมไปปาร์ตี้แล้วครูหญิง
ไปปาร์ตี้ที่ไหนครูหญิงไปปาร์ตี้ที่กรุง
ปาร์ตี้เนี่ยที่อยู่ที่กรุงเทพฯนะคะเป็น
คอนโดมิเนียมไปอันนี้ครูหญิงใช่ไหมมครู
หญิงเป็นครูก็จะมีนักเรียนมเป็นปาร์ตี้
ของนักเรียนเ่อนักเรียนเไม่มีผมม้านะคะ
นักเรียนผู้หญิงนักเรียนคนนี้เนี่ยอันนี้
คอนโดมิเนียมของเาเขาก็บอกว่าครูหญิงมา
จริงๆเขาก็บอกว่าครูฟ้ามาอปาร์ตี้เหมือน
กันนะคะแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเทพฯ
ใช่ก็เป็น
คอนโดมิเนียมของนักเรียนค่ะปาร์ตี้เนี่ย
แล้วครูหญิงทำอะไรที่ปาร์ตี้ล่ะูหญิงจำ
ได้เลยค่ะครูหญิงกิน
พิซซ่ากินพิซซ่าผู้หญิงกินพิซซ่าที่
ปาร์ตี้หรอใช่ค่ะนักนักเรียนเนี่ยเขาคก็
จะมีแบบโอพิซซ่าใช่มั้ยพิซซ่า
พิซซ่าแล้วก็พิซซ่าแล้วก็ครูหญิงก็เล่น
เกมเกมครูหญิงจำไม่ได้แล้วว่าเกมอะไรนะ
เพราะว่าในปาร์ตี้เนี่ยมีคนน่าจะมีผู้ชาย
เนาะแล้วก็ผู้หญิงน่าจะประมาณแบบ 10 คน
อืออืมีคนไทยมีฝร
มีคนญี่ปุ่นนะคะก็กินพิซซ่าเล่นเกมแต่จำ
จำเกมไม่ได้นะคะเล่นเกมด้วยอือืก็สนุกมย
ครูหญิงสนุกนะได้คือครูหญิงไปเนี่ยครู
หญิงรู้จักนักเรียน 1 คนแล้วก็คนทั้งหมด
ในปาร์ตี้เนี่ยคุหญิงใครใครใครใครไม่รู้
จัก
อือครูหญิงไปปาร์ตี้กี่โมงครูหญิงไป
ปาร์ตี้เนี่ยเอ่อ 600 นค่ะครูฟ้า 18:00 น
600 นเนี่ยถึง
คอนโดมิเนียมอืมแล้วอยู่ถึงกี่โมงคะ 600
นครูหญิงออกจากคอนโดมิเนียมน่าจะ 22:00 น
นะครูฟ้าอื 22:00 น 22 นอโอูหญิงผู้หญิง
อยู่ 18 น 19 น 2 น 21:00 น 22:00 นก็
อยู่ที่ปาร์ตี้เนี่ย 4 ชมงนะอยู่ใน
ปาร์ตี้ 4 ชมงอือๆๆก็โอเคมโอเคค่ะเพราะ
ว่าจริงๆเนี่ย
ปารตี้มันจัดตอนประมาณวันที่ 10 วันที่ 11
ใช่มั้ยคะแต่ว่าอันยเป็นปาร์ตี้คริสมาสนะ
นักเรียนบอกอืเออเป็นแบบเป็นปาร์ตี้
คริสต์มาสแต่ไม่มีต้นคริสต์มาสนะ
คะไม่มีต้นคริสต์มาสเหรอต้นคริสต์มาส
เนี่ยไม่มีเนาะเพราะว่าประเทศไทยนะคะต้น
คริสต์มาสอาจจะหาไม่ได้อืใช่ค่ะใช่ต้น
คริสต์มาสหายากนะคะอืใช่ค่ะก็สนุกนะครู
ฟ้าเพราะว่ามีคนเยอะๆได้เล่นเกมใชมมีเกม
เกมให้เล่นนะคะุหญิงก็จำเกมไม่ได้เนาะว่า
ปกติถ้าเป็นคนไทยคน
ไทยไม่ใช่นักเรียนครูหญิงก็ไม่เคยไป
ปาร์ตี้นะออมใช่ครุหญิงก็จะไปแค่คนไทยใช่
มยปกติอืถ้าสมมุติครูหญิงใช่มั้ยคะมีครู
หญิงครูฟ้าครูเอ๋อ่ะครูเรียม 4 คนเนี่ยไป
ไหนด้วยกันมันเราก็ไม่ได้ไปปาร์ตี้ไงกิน
ข้าวใช่มกินข้าวอ่าหรือว่าวันเกิดใช่มั้ย
Happy  Birthday ครูฟ้าวันเกิดครูฟ้าก็
มีปาร์ตี้วันเกิดครูหญิงก็ไม่มีปาร์ตี้คน
ไทยไม่ค่อยมีปาร์ตี้เท่าไหร่เพื่อนครู
หญิงแล้วกันนะไม่ค่อยมีนะคะขนาดครูฟ้าไป
ปาร์ตี้ก็ยังเป็นปาร์ตี้ที่เป็นคอนเสิร์ต
ใช่มั้ยร้องเพลงใชร้องเพลงคอนเสิร์ตอะไร
แบบนั้นเลยนะคะอันนี้ก็เลยเป็นใช่ค่ะ
ปาร์ตี้ใช่ไมยใช่ปาร์ตี้ครั้งล่าสุดนะคะ
ของครูหญิงเนี่ยปีที่แล้วของครูฟ้าเนี่ย 2
ปีที่แล้วแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะปาร์ตี้ครั้ง
ล่าสุดของนักเรียนเนี่ยเมื่อไหร่คอมเมนต์
บอกเราได้เนาะส่วนวดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเรามาเจอกันใหม่วดีโอ
หน้าสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ